KYIV IR MORE DRONESTKER THE
ED UKRAINE FOR A
WERE DAMAGED AND TWONTIAL BUDI
UKRAINE DENIES ANY DIRECT S ATT.
BUT IT T LATEST  THAT
THE WAR ULG A NE
PHASE.
PRESIDENT LENSKYAID TH OF
UKRAINE'S SIVE HAS
A LOS BEEN GOING ON THESE EAK D
LAST 24 S, JIM.
BRING US UP TO SO, IS THAT
UKRAINE IS PROVING ITS ABILI
TO STRIKE IN RUSSIAN-CONOLY.
RUSSIAN-CONTROLLED TERTORY
SION BUTLSY DE RUSSIA.
R  BALL GA
RAUT I.
AND N TARGETS THERE,
ITH DRONES NOWKRAINENOT CLAIMED
BUT THEY HAVE NODENIED DIRECT  E
HO TIMING ATY LINEEV OE RUSSIA
HERE IS THVANCE OF THIHIGHLY A
COFFSIBIATTACK
THERE BUT AL RUSSIA ONS  TO  KNT
>> IS ASINSAIDRRACTIVIT
ASOUIAN TOP
OFFICIALS ARSAD
HAVEECT, KEYWO
INVOLVEMENT IN WHAT HAPPENED
MOSCOWWHAT MORE OW ABOUT HOW
>> ST KNOW SE USED.
WE KNOW INT UKRAINS
S
GOES BACK TO TH
NOT AS CAPAB OF DR.
TOOUPON'T
DENY -- THEY'RE DENYING
RESPONSIBILITY.NOT Y
RESPONSIBILITY HERE.AT'S K W
WAR.RUSSIAOUR S  UKRAINE
TA UKR
HE
LASTHOS ANGO,
U , ROSS T CNT
SO FOR UKRAINE TTACK A
RSI
ST COUE TENSION UKRAINE AND ITNA
BACKERE U.S.  TGE
BECAUSE IT HAS GIVEN THEE GH GR
>> R.
COURSE, INCLUDING
THE , HAVE GIVEN UKRAINE NSS.
>> BUT THERE'S ALWAYS BEEN THAT
SHOULD NOT BE  THAT COULD BE TEN
USINT UKRAIN
EVIDENCE THAT US
STRIKERIRYTSN OW.
THAT COULD CREATDIVISIONINE AND
PRTOA'ATTAILIAN TARGETS
INSIDE UKRAINE.
BUT IT'SESTING, TOO, THAT
THE U.S.-SUPPLIED PATRION
HELPING SAVE L T
UKRAINE IN THE WAKE OF THOSE
ATTA TION.
THEY'VE BEENY SUCCESSFUL.D NOT O
OF THESE THIS BECAUS
HAS BEENAC-   RKRAINE
UNPROVOKED AND IT'S BEEN
TARGETS FORD A HALF SINCE
IT INVADED UKRAINE GOING
FEBRUARY.
>> CAN'T LOSE SIGHT OF THAFOR
SUSCIUTTO, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>>> LET'S PERSPECTIVE
S.SADOR E TOE,ER THE MBU FOR CO.
HERE I HSAID.
PATH OF INTIMIDATION OF SSND ON
NTIAL BUILDINGS.
A CLEAR SIGN OF IST
>> SO, CALLING THI
ACTIVITY SUGGESTS HO
HE TAKES THID
COTADO YOU TNK FOR EN
E ICS?>> WELL, F I THINKF
PUTIN COULD USE MOREE
TACTICS HE WOULDLRE
IT.
MORE, HE WOULD.D I THS G HERE
IS REALLY ABOUT TRYING TREASSURH
THERE E LYAC
SOMETHING THEY HAD N SEEN
HE'S CALLED THIS AMILITARY OPERN
HED THAT THIS NG AGAINST N
D W ACTUALLY S HAPPENING INSIDEE
AND HE TRYING TO C
NARRATIVE.
>> WHAT DOESMEE
CT THAT RUSSIAN CIVILIANARW FEEI
THE THII
B TTH
THE IDEAT  ITUALLY A
WAR.
TITO A SPECIAL MILITY OPATAWAYDG
SIAI A
IFE FACT TNOT
WHAT'S HAPPENINGS ALREADY ENT T.
RUOST SO MANY
MUCH EQUIPMENT.
NE ON SO
NOW THAT THEY SEE SOMETHIN
INA, I
BUT E NT TO COME T SAID,
WHICH HE IS MAKING AN ASSUMPTHA
DON'T KNOW THAT
D TARGETSTHE FIRED WERE SHOT D
BY RUSSIA.
W WHERE THEYER
EN MILITARY
TARGETS.ON'TW.
WE ALSO DON' THE
RE FRO WHO DID IT.AND SO, I THI
FACILITATED THIS IN SOME WAY,
SO WN'T JUO 'TNO
ASSUMPON TALK
DI INVOLVEMENT, BUT HOAT?
CAREFULORD
SELECTION THERE.EV REPOR T
PICKED UP CHATTER
OF UKR KREMLIN
YEAH.
T THIN THAT
REMEMBER LASEK WE SAW THTACKS I
GATHERED SOME TA MADE ANSION TI
COULD DO
THEY PROBABLY COULT HAVE DONE T
UKRAINNST UKRAINE CONDUCTING TH.
BECAUSE IT'S A THE
A LOT OF AIR DEFENSES ONTH
SO FOR THESE DRONES TO GET THERR
WEREN'T D FROM UKRAINE
EVEN THEN, WT KNOW WHO
ITN SPECIAL
E KIND